[Musique]
affaires de viol d'agression
d'harcèlement quel que soit le sujet
souvent les médias sont emparés la
machine ne sert d'être plus près chabert
est accusée d'inceste par sa fille aînée
patrick poivre d'arvor qui faisait
l'objet d'une enquête pour viol et
agression sexuelle d'autant plus lorsque
ces affaires concernent des célébrités
pourtant en france il existe la
présomption d'innocence un principe
selon lequel on ne doit pas rendre
coupable un individu avant qu'il ne soit
jugé et tant que vous n'avez pas été
déclarés coupables
vous êtes présumé innocent mais les
récentes polémiques ont montré que
souvent la télévision la presse les
réseaux sociaux s'installa en tribunal
médiatique pour commenter ces affaires
richard berry dément fermement toute
accusation d'inceste c'est le cas dans
la sphère luc besson qui avait été
accusé de viol par l'actrice anne van
rooy une enquête pour viol visant le
besson a été classée sans suite ou
encore de patrick poivre d'arvor accusé
lui par l'écrivaine florence porcel au
moins deux viols dans les années 2000
des histoires qui ont pourtant abouti à
des non lieux selon voici aujourd'hui
ses lecteurs un les habitants qui
seraient en garde à vue pour une plainte
déposée pour viol par sa compagne alors
la justice doit elle se faire dans les
médias
médias nous ont rejoints avi bitton qui
vient souvent nous voir un avocat
spécialisé en droit des médias et jérôme
mouloud des chômeurs et jérôme boulons
qu'on aime bien jérôme rédacteur en chef
d'entrevue merci d'être là jérôme
également plus cher c'est vrai que alors
on va revenir déjà sur la sphère ppda la
sphère ppda l' enquête pour viol a été
classée sans suite en juin dernier à
cause de l'insuffisance de preuves est
sain
mais glisse donc c'est ça ouais je peux
vous dire il a été accusé de viol et
d'agression sexuelle
patrick poivre d'arvor a bénéficié de
l'insuffisance des preuves apportées par
les accusatrices et document de 24 pages
d'une psychologue est à l'origine du
classement décidée par la justice alors
qu en tant qu il est totalement blanchi
l'instant voilà mes bras sur richard
berry où on l enquête s'il vous plaît
oui alors richard berry charlie il
enquête préliminaire est toujours en
cours ouais elle est ouverte en janvier
dernier ces investigations ont été
confiées à la brigade de protection des
mineurs pour l'instant voilà ces
collines berry qui a accusé son père la
police a entendu tout le monde l'a déjà
plusieurs mois et en entendant donc il
ya deux clans qui se déchire au sein de
la famille et la police a mis à jour dès
propos par sms sur instagram sur les
réseaux sociaux qui étaient des
correspondances dit privé mais que
chaque membre de la famille a montré aux
enquêteurs alors il semble que ça ça
continue sur la rai arbitres on a leur a
les infos donne un sens parce qu on
entend tout et son contraire et ce n'est
pas sa compagne l'avait vu dans le kit
est plein on en parlera dans un instant
sur luc besson le parquet de paris a
requis le 8 octobre dernier un non-lieu
il revient désormais à la juge
d'instruction chargés de ce dossier de
confirmer ou pas ce non-lieu c'est vrai
quoi et donc c'est vrai que là on voit
et un non-lieu pour luc besson pour
l'instant il ya eu sur ppda classée sans
suite et c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
que la justice se fait dans les médias
on va parler de la ferme je vous dis
arrive dans un instant c'est vrai qu'on
dit que à partir du moment où hausse et
dans les médias la justice et est déjà
fait et que la décision ait déjà le mal
et est déjà faits la justice doit elle
se faire dans les médias vous dit non ah
oui en fait la culture du buzz et la
course à l'info racoleuse et instantanée
sont en train de tuer complètement la
présomption d'innocence parce que même
si ces articles emploie le conditionnel
même si il n'accuse personne en fait le
mal est fait le nom de toutes ces
personnalités ont été salis on les
associe à des violeurs et ce qui
m'énerve encore plus c'est que quand les
affaires ne sont pas jugés ou quand ils
sont innocents la com gaza il ya plus
aucun article un grand bus c'est même un
travail journalistique ça travaille
c'est vrai qu'il ya moins d'un an suite
à ces maïs
est vrai qu'à moi d'articles quand la
personne est innocente et oui c'est ça
qui est fou me direz que ça leur fait
plaisir de se taper des vedettes mais
c'est normal aussi mais là où ils sont a
priori
célèbre parce qu'ils ont je sais pas il
ya une espèce de notoriété et du coup
ils sont coupables parce qu'ils sont
célèbres mais à chaque fois c'est pareil
moi je croyais moi toutes ces
personnalités que l'on voit derrière moi
tout le monde me dit mais si c'est sûr
richard berry poivre d'arvor c'est
toujours la même histoire mais qui sont
célèbres dans les îles sont ils sont
condamnés sont cadel evans qui sont
condamnés déjà médiatique hémodialysés
condamné chelsea et les titres c'est
affreux parce qu'en plus ça reste ces
titres là maintenant désormais ary
abittan je vais en parler avant par les
justes et un connecteur n'a pas tout à
fait
richard berry mais dès que vous verrez
ça vous verrez des coûts taper leur nom
sur google ou ailleurs ça ressort
systématiquement ils sont condamnés à
vie avec ses histoires même s'ils sont
classés sans suite ou en tout les a
blanchis c'est ça qui est terrible vers
des excréments mais dans une démocratie
bernard montiel ça s'appelle tout
simplement le droit à l'information mais
à des plaintes qui sont déposées quand
il ya une plainte qui est déposée les
enquêteurs sont au courant bien entendu
les victimes les personnes accusées les
avocats donc ça sort dans la presse des
traditions de la liberté de la presse
française est ok tu dis ça mais le droit
à l'information ok si tu es sûr de ma
passion voilà ce que le problème moi je
pense que la justice a besoin de deux
temps et de sérénité pour travailler
c'est pas pour blanchir qui que ce soit
mais laissons travailler la justice
mieux parce qu'il le dépasse 6 terry's à
partir de mousse et sur la voie publique
enfin le sur la place publique et oui il
en faut et jean-luc si vous laissez
travailler la justice aucune affaire me
sort on ne parlera de rien ici
quand c'est avéré c'est que les gens qui
leur annonce assuré un peu plus tôt vous
faites après que ce qu'on fait après
conducteurs y est alors de charb et riss
sa carrière certes et n'a eu d'envolées
sur cette affaire avec 18 il a perdu les
locaux vides et courir mais
immédiatement son téléfilm et il y avait
deux projets de films et ont été annulés
notamment résultat que je méritais
cerveau alors que matthieu delormeau
wish n'envisage abri parce
qu'effectivement il travaille toujours
tout ça mais c'est vrai qu'on associe
systématiquement le nom le problème
aussi c'est que maintenant ensuite avec
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde s'en
mêle il monde donne son avis dans le cas
de richard berry pardon mais c'était
ridicule elie chouraqui réalisateur qui
twitte nom richard est un mec très bien
non billy houle adore même train de
violer on peut ne pas dieu de retraite
avec très bien sans mais alors il
faudrait la défense de son ami après
voilà on peut pas lui en vouloir arrêter
un outil
aux il ya effectivement les médias et ya
les réseaux sociaux les médias le boulot
de journaliste quand il a quand il a une
information et la publie après les
réseaux sociaux il s'emballe et la balle
c'est la machine qui s'emballe on n'y
peut rien mais à un moment tu ne peux
pas reprocher un journaliste de sortir
une affaire ça c'est ça c'est un métier
ce que même il ya quand même un tribunal
médiatique est extrêmement violent parce
que la présomption d'innocence n'existe
plus et la présomption de culpabilité et
pendant une semaine ils sont broyés ses
chips tom chercher storm et on décide
que de toute façon ce sens mais là non
bernard il ya aussi des histoires comme
ça qui sont sortis par les réseaux
sociaux par ballon sans porc pas me
parler tout parce que les gens ont parlé
comme ça médiatiquement wang xin epstein
duhamel excuse moi c'est des gens quand
même qui avait fait des choses très
graves qui avaient été des violeurs ça
est récidiviste et c'est sorti comme ça
c'est sorti par les médias donc tu as
sorti dans les volumes d'abord moi oui
les livres n'ont pas pas forcément ce
qu'il
ou elle pour moi le problème le vrai
problème c'est la justice parce que
comme on reconnaît aujourd'hui que
quelqu'un a été violée c'est parole
contre parole
vraiment fait ça s'est passé il ya dix
ans il ya 15 ans il ya vingt ans qu'on
n'a pas pu faire l'examen médical juste
après comment on fait pour quoi pour
prouver que la personne a été violée
donc le problème c'est la justice la
lenteur de la justice et la prescription
sur de toute façon maintenant tout est
prévu de 10 ou 15 ans vous aviez bitton
avocat spécialisé en droit des médias
vous dénoncez vraiment ce ce tribunal
médiatique moi je pense qu'il faut
laisser la justice faire son travail la
prescription aujourd'hui pour une
accusation de viol et de 20 ans je
rappelle qu'il ya quelques temps elle
était de 10 ans elle a été doublée à 20
ans ce délai de vingt ans pour les
mineurs les victimes mineures commence à
courir à compter de leur majorité et
dans certains cas maintenant il a été
augmenté à 30 ans donc la justice à tous
les moyens de faire son travail elle
fait son travail est simplement dans les
médias parce que une personne qui a une
affaire comme ça voilà je vous le dis on
l'a vu là sur ppda l' enquête pour viol
a été classée sans suite c'est vrai que
c'était très peu repris on apprenait à
-10 et voilà non mais si ça a été mais
très abîmé fait est ce que une fois que
les médias se sont emparés de la sphère
la personne médiatiquement
c'est compliqué pour elle bien
évidemment même si derrière voilà à ppda
jaulin de personnes va répondre dans les
médias va riposter va faire des droits
de réponse et plus ça va entretenir le
feu médiatique et la polémique c'est le
paradoxe est que même maintenant
regarder plus de six heures il a mérité
non là vous dit des prêts pda il a
pratiquement rien fait et ppda ces voix
là il s'est fait tout le monde en a
parlé c'est comme gérard depardieu il a
rien fait enfin il a il a rien fait dans
les médias pour parler de ça
mais ce non plus donc ça c'est qu'ils
viennent à quand les mecs qui est la
limite vaut peut-être mieux en parler
dans les médias et à la limite et 1 2 le
feu plutôt que de laisser traîner aussi
la sphère soyez j'ai eu poivre d'arvor
tout à l'heure il m'a dit qu'on lui
parle que de ça et qui sans même dans le
regard maintenant des femmes qui
croisent ceux qui rencontrent ça cette
histoire elle est là il est marié à prix
allaient vraiment il ya des victimes
aussi
exactement là où il ya des victimes
aussi mais qui elles aussi sont
traumatisés et leur vie est foutue donc
voilà donc mais c'est vrai que là on
parle de ce soir du tribunal ah oui mais
médiatique guillaume jean ziegler que
c'était de l'information par langil mais
c'est pas de la formation ça nourrit
juste l'esprit voyeur et et racoleur des
gens sympas sont là si c'est
l'information il faut sortir toutes les
personnes qui tous les jours sont
accusés de viol pourquoi on sur
l'information est ce que c'est le rôle
de la presse de sortir l'information la
presse elle sort l'information parce que
c'est une personnalité parce que ça va
générer du clic et c'est tout voilà si
c'est vraiment une information à ce
moment là qu'on sorte toutes les
personnes qui sont accusées de gueule
c'est pas le cas c'est que les
personnalités voilà et la seule chose
qui entre guillemets est un avantage
pour ces personnes là si ce n'est pas
vrai c'est la multiplication de ces
affaires il ya tellement de personnes
qui sont maintenant accusé de
harcèlement sexuel de l'agression et de
viol que tout ça s'est noyé dans une
masse et heureusement pour ceux qui sont
pas coupables oui mais attention aussi
comme a dit géraldine tout à l'heure oui
ç'a permis sexy ça c'est grâce à ça
qu'il a permis de dénoncer de nombreuses
affaires c'était extrêmement grave
heureusement c'est arrivé n'aurait c'est
vrai que j'ai insulté et aptes à mieux
tu as bien fait de le faire tout à
l'heure vous benjamin castaldi vous
dites oui c'est le rôle des médias voilà
il ya une affaire c'est pas pour ça que
le il est coupable ou pas c'est normal
qu'un magazine journal voilà une
information là où je suis d'accord avec
toi c'est qu'effectivement derrière mais
c'est la peine dont il présente un faux
ils ont appris qu'il est coupable mais
ça quand c'est un politique ça dérange
personne quand c'est un comédien ou un
artiste chanteur là pour le coup tout le
monde ya là c'est un scandale donc dans
le cas d'incapacité qui ment il ya une
info la voilà on la traite ou du paquet
les coupables ou pas mais c'est tout à
fait normal alors chez nous il ya plus
de presse et puis journalisme on est
souvent que c'est alors sauf que dans
tous les cas que par dans tous les cas
non sire il vient de parler il ya eu des
non lieux à chaque fois non pas château
on attend pour la suite et bien voilà le
besson besson lui aussi pardon pour
l'instant ils cessèrent en grande
majorité c'était de non lieu voilà donc
la presse et à massacrer effectivement
c'est au rythme et on les associe
forcément à ça que tu vas parler des
habitants je ne sais pas comment ça va
c'est une scéne horreur je ne vois pas
je ne vois pas la suite de la carrière
pour ce pour ce on espère mais je
connais pas l'histoire des histoires
personnelles espère qu'il y arrive et
horrible et on est tous pareils et
richard berry pareil mais dès qu'on me
c'est moi dès qu'on me cite son nom
aujourd'hui je m'associe à un viol et
ses torts et donc appris peut plus rien
faire gagner pas pour moi c'est très
compliqué effectivement malgré le
non-lieu pour moi c'est en sciences et à
la presse inquiète tic a parlé en coin
bien sûr et aime c'est vrai que ça
a été relayée par la boîte c'est de fait
assez bien sûr c'est un cap oui j'ai lu
harry l'aube allemand mathieu on n'est
pas là dans de l' ingérence dans la vie
privée on est dans des affaires avec
dépôt de plainte oui contient un dépôt
de plainte d'une victime présumée oui
présumée elle a le droit de s'exprimer
même vous n'allez pas ériger un comité
de censure non irrévérence et de médéa
aujourd'hui un non-lieu et non d alors
mais d'autres manières tout le monde ici
aujourd'hui associe le nom de ppda à ça
donc c'est horrible il a gagné mais l'a
perdu mais les victimes ont droit de
s'exprimer londres et dans ce cas là il
voulait fumer je le précise présentera
guide tous les jours hymne dans la vraie
vie de tous les jours tu es boulanger tu
es ce que tu veux liens non lieu
personne ne sera au tour des marchés
mais derrière orange
pour sa carrière est derrière et c'est
terminé mais ferait que j'étais
aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est fini quelle
désolation donc on ne traite pas des
affaires dont la sadc victimes dans
leurs silos l'abri les miens comme on
l'a fait avant lui faire plus de chiens
a dit qu'il a dit pardon c'est que la
solution c'est vrai que là le problème
c'est que la justice était la justice je
peux pas aller plus vite art et essai
mais parfois je tape lire ses poèmes
idée de la faire il faut juste traiter
une information apprécié elle si elle
s'avère aimerait passer comme et 103
regardant 3,4 mais ça veut dire que me
paraît donc la personne ne fait plus
rien pendant trois quatre ans et ça et
donc à l est on inverse elle est à
l'écouté cependant trois voies entre
avec 8 jérôme geronimo qui est avec le
rédacteur en chef d'entrevue vous la
justice médiatique comprenez un peu
voilà qui est des gens qui puissent la
critique est alors déjà comme la chine
le disais tout à l'heure on est en
république il faut savoir quand il ya
des audiences dans les tribunaux les
audiences ils sont publics sont
récompensés des mineurs donc déjà partis
ou mouvements une audience et public
dans un tribunal je ne vois pas pourquoi
dans la presse on ne pourrait pas parler
d'une affaire ensuite effectivement il
faut respecter la présomption
d'innocence le problème c'est que
pendant des années des années il ya une
véritable omerta sur les violences
sexuelles s'est faite aux fans pendant
des années les victimes ne pouvait pas
parler elles avaient peur de parler vrai
même il y avait une sorte d'inversion
des valeurs avec les victimes qui
devenait coupables et les bourreaux qui
devenait victime est aujourd'hui porte
alors que la libération que les femmes
peuvent enfin se libérer de la pour
dénoncer les violences sexuelles dont
elles sont victimes alors parfois à tort
parfois raison pourquoi est-ce qu
interdire aux médias d'en parler après
le problème qui a dans leur histoire de
viol je finis là dessus c'est le
problème des viols cc souvent parole
contre parole c'est souvent difficile
d'avoir des preuves et malheureusement
c'est vrai que pour harry habitants si
l'ex il est innocent c'est horrible ce
qui lui arrive mais s'il est coupable
c'est au risque pour la victime autres
exact mais mecelec a notre preneur
n'importe quoi il vend un produit qui a
reconnu son produit c'est lui oui ça
marque c'est lui donc de toutes façons
vous dites ces publics et si l'audience
est publique et donné sur demande s'il
reste dix ans c'est une personne qui est
public c'était un homme et sa carrière
l'exterminer donc la photo mais bien
s'il est innocenté par la justice ce
sera de la faute des médias qui ont
parlé là pour le coup c'est l'info c'est
il est mis en garde à vue la garde à vue
a été prolongée c'est un fait établi ça
veut pas dire qu'il est coupable nancy
demain des problèmes énormes ainsi de ne
plus l'embauché c'est de la faute des
médias où c'est de la faute et
producteur qui vous ne plus embaucher
alors que la démesure l'instant dans la
tête des gens aujourd'hui s'ils arrivent
à un viol c'est horrible et non mais le
bureau
la chauffage qui sait pas ce que les
gens pensent qu'il est coupable que
c'est la faute des médias les médias
dominants fresque pour les gens quant à
mehdi a donné l'info c'est forcément
l'adversaire médias ne donnent pas d'un
jour ça donne à jouer aujourd'hui les
gens sont schizophrènes c'est à dire que
pendant des années on a accusé les
médias de pratiquer la chape de plomb
d'y avoir une omerta de masquer
certaines affaires je rappelle l'
affaire dsk tout le monde disait tout le
monde sait mais personne n'a dit donc
quand les médias ne disent rien qu'on
dise qu'ils sont complices des violeurs
et qui veulent cacher la vérité et quand
les médias pas l'on dise oui il lancé
vous plaît s'il vous plaît que
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la sphère
d'aujourd'hui où il arrive qu'on va en
parler avec bernard montiel alors oui
non monsieur vous avez commencé par dire
une contre vérité vous avez dit au lieu
de toute façon s'il ya un procès pour
viol il sera public c'est faux c'est
faux pas remettez me permettez moi la
plaignante a le droit de demander le
huis clos je défends des victimes de
forcément je peux vous dire que à peu
près une
demande le huis clos et si elle le
demande dans une affaire de viol il est
de droit il est automatique vous donc
imaginer dans cette affaire que la
plaignante ne va ulpat que son affaire
se répondent sur la place publique qu'on
sache qu'elle a été victime de viol vous
prenez une responsabilité immense en
révélant la face à naples